[Música]
Bienvenidos a este programa especial
sobre los efectos del cambio climático
en la salud pero también sobre las
alternativas que desde hoy en día ya se
están construyendo para hacer frente a
un futuro incierto el cambio climático
es el principal problema de salud
pública que existe de hecho la
Organización Mundial de la Salud Calcula
que entre 2030 y 2050 el cambio
climático provocará al menos 250.000
muertes anuales especialmente por culpa
de la desnutrición infantil Al haber
menos producción y menos acceso a
alimentos y por el aumento también de
las enfermedades que se transmiten por
vectores Como por ejemplo el paludismo
la malaria la falta de acceso a agua
potable también hará crecer la
transmisión de enfermedades como el
cólera que de hecho hoy en día Ya están
repuntando pero más allá de eso los
desastres climáticos también tendrán un
impacto muy directo el 67% de los
centros de salud del continente
americano dos tercios del total están en
zonas proclives a los desastres
naturales un ejemplo en nuestra Puerto
Rico desgraciadamente familiarizado con
Los huracanes que cada vez serán más
frecuentes el huracán María dejó muchos
centros de salud sin energía por ejemplo
y sin la posibilidad de atender a Los
afectados sin embargo un centro de
emergencias médicas y de bomberos de
adjuntas en el oeste de Puerto Rico
buscaron una alternativa sostenible
gracias a la organización civil casa
pueblo instalaron un sistema de energía
solar nosotros pudimos entrevistar a un
bombero y un paramédico de esta
organización que nos contaron la
importancia de su trabajo en este tipo
de situaciones y también de los
problemas con los cortes de energía
escuchémoslo ahí cuando salimos a la
calle es que nos encontramos la realidad
de cómo está la Cómo quedó nuestro
Puerto Rico Cómo quedó nuestra junta
tuvimos que mover personas para que no
tenían energía y dependen de un
ventilador mecánico pues las movemos a
un lugar verdad Y eso es bastante
pacientes tuvimos que mover de esa
manera o dependiente de oxígeno que al
no tener energía pues hay que llevarlos
a centros que son que tengan energía les
pudimos preguntar también por cómo
pasaron el huracán Fiona en el pasado
mes de septiembre ahora con el sistema
de energía solar y esto nos contaron y
de verdad Ahora comparándolo huracán
María con el huracán Fiona que
recientemente tuvimos pues no tuvimos
interrupción absoluta ninguna de lo que
es el servicio de energía solar
pegado a eso pues nunca se interrumpió
el sistema de nosotros tanto como el
sistema de de bomberos tanto como si
traen a nosotros de emergencia médica
cuando está la emergencia el huracán no
puede irse para su casa tiene que
quedarse en la estación Pero eso nos
ayudó también a nosotros hasta a pasar
un poco más más suave la situación que
estamos pasando por ejemplo ahí tenemos
nuestros alimentos tenemos la nevera por
el televisor también vimos Dónde estaba
pasando porque ya los celulares pierden
la señal por el televisor pudimos ver
dónde estaba pasando En qué lugar Cuándo
salió el huracán de Puerto Rico O sea
que no fue de gran ayuda
y Finalmente nos contaron de su
agradecimiento por la organización casa
pueblo pero también por el problema ya
que esta llena un vacío de un gobierno
que debería estar solucionando estos
problemas
Bueno tan solo pensaron nosotros que
eran un buen servicio sino que pensaron
en el pueblo y de esto se trata desde de
de de que hay un problema y cómo mitigar
eso De qué manera nos ayudaron Qué
bonito que que ante lo que está
ocurriendo haya personas que pongan las
manos en el arado Para qué para trabajar
porque las cosas sean mejores y estamos
bien agradecidos de ellos
Nos gustaría también que pues que el
gobierno se entrara ya que está se
integrara a esa gran iniciativa porque
es para beneficio no tanto de nosotros
es para el pueblo de Puerto Rico que se
beneficia de eso que el gobierno se
compenetrará más y te dé manera más
comunicación en relación y para mejor de
como digo de servicio a nuestro pueblo
nos quedamos en el continente americano
para conocer otro ejemplo de preparación
frente al cambio climático hablamos del
wol de mosquito program una iniciativa
global que en Colombia ensaya Cómo
proteger a las comunidades de
enfermedades como el dengue o el
chikungunya el aumento de las
temperaturas hará que los mosquitos
vectores de estas enfermedades lleguen a
más personas y a más territorios pero
esta innovadora propuesta centrada en la
prevención podría ayudar a mitigar este
problema del futuro viajamos a las
ciudades de Cali y de Medellín Con
Juanita González para conocer el
proyecto
y además de eso los mosquitos son los
animales más mortíferos del mundo pero
en este laboratorio de Medellín Colombia
pasan de ser villanos a superhéroes
están infectados con una bacteria común
la volvaquia que impide que el mosquito
transmita los virus del dengue del zika
o del Chikungunya como Si estuvieran
vacunados
Este es el mosquito adulto bajo la
supervisión del profesor Iván Darío
Vélez del World mosquito project cada
semana producen 7 millones de insectos
para dejarlos volar en las ciudades y
que se reproduzcan hasta que todos los
mosquitos sean vacunados el año pasado
tuvimos el menor número de casos en toda
la historia de la ciudad desde que se
está contabilizando el dengue pero lo
interesante es que mientras tanto el
país es tan epidemia o sea Colombia está
en epidemia grandísima
estas enfermedades son un problema del
presente pero también del futuro el
calentamiento global hará que los
mosquitos lleguen a lugares que antes
eran demasiado fríos la gente que vive
en esa franja Donde antes no estábamos
el mosquito y ahora sí son altamente
susceptibles a sufrir todas estas
enfermedades si yo tengo la ciudad con
mosquitos con volvaquia la tengo
blindada de la llegada de esos virus una
protección que los científicos calculan
que puede durar 80 años ahora Cali Busca
seguir los pasos de Medellín un grupo de
voluntarias pasó meses liberando
manualmente miles de mosquitos con
walkie en Charco azul un barrio de
Invasión donde precisamente enfermedades
como el dengue o el chikungunya han
causado estragos Delia una de las
voluntarias Recuerda la epidemia de 2016
así o lo que sí mire que las personas
fueron muy afectadas por el chikungunya
muy fuerte en las personas adultos
mayores que ya no volvieron a tomar a
tener su movilidad como habitualmente lo
hacían Y aunque la persona eran joven
aunque las personas eran joven también
les impacto muchísimo Delia tuvo que
convencer a sus vecinos puerta a puerta
para que la dejaran liberar los
mosquitos o zancudos como les llaman en
Colombia en nosotros nos hicimos le
hicimos a las personas que era un
control biológico que estábamos haciendo
que aunque la población de San Juan
había aumentado que por favor nos
aguantaran y que era criando zancosanos
que ya no nos iban a enfermar entonces
que por favor no soportara un poquito
ahí la verdad
ahora el trabajo de Delia lo completa un
dron cargado de mosquitos los libera de
forma precisa cada 50 metros cuando
termine esta fase del proyecto
Aproximadamente en la mitad de Cali
estará protegida por los insectos
gracias a personas como Delia y gracias
a las innovaciones tecnológicas del
proyecto que soña con levantar el vuelo
para otras ciudades de Colombia de
latinoamérica y del mundo
y para terminar vamos a hablar de uno de
los efectos del cambio climático menos
visibles la Salud Mental además de una
multitud de problemas que pueden
aparecer a raíz de la emergencia
climática los desastres naturales y las
migraciones desde ya la angustia a un
futuro que nos espera tiene
consecuencias hoy en día la han llamado
ecoansiedad y desde France 24
preguntamos a través de nuestra de
nuestras redes sociales Si la audiencia
compartía estas angustias para recibir
consejos de cómo hacerle frente
precisamente nos conectamos con Javier
Urbina catedrático de psicología de la
Universidad Nacional Autónoma de México
profesor tuvimos varias respuestas que
hablaron por ejemplo del miedo de tener
hijos un usuario nos decía que Había
decidido no tenerlos precisamente por el
miedo a lo que podrían sufrir Qué le
respondería a este espectador
bien
el volumen o el asunto de la población
humana en el planeta siempre ha sido un
gran tema ahora bien la idea de no tener
hijos por razones de incertidumbre ante
las condiciones del planeta o por
razones sociales o por circunstancias
económicas ya se viene presentando desde
finales del siglo pasado pero ahora está
aumentando el número de personas que
Residen no tener descendencia o que
tienen dudas acerca de ello es Claro que
las condiciones ambientales pueden
empeorar para las próximas generaciones
pero ojo también está la opción de que
mejore si quienes actualmente habitamos
el planeta razonamos un tanto mal
nuestros estilos de vida y de consumo
las condiciones pueden cambiar Es decir
no hay un destino fatal para que les
vengan al mundo en los próximos lustros
podemos lograr mejores condiciones
ambientales pero es una labor colectiva
lo mismo del plano local en el ámbito
global o colectivo por lo tanto más que
decidir no tener hijos Quizás lo conven
impugnar porque les dejemos un mejor
lugar
profesor otro tema que surgió
repetidamente es la desazón frente Por
ejemplo a la sobreproducción de objetos
a la basura que se acumula de hecho
habían usuarios que nos comentaban que
hasta tenían pesadillas con eso qué
consejo tiene
sí la generación de desechos es otro de
los grandes temas vinculados también con
los estilos de vida y agravado Ojo por
las formas de producción y las formas de
empaquetado por fortuna hay tanto
planteamientos sociales como paradigmas
conceptuales que nos pueden ayudar uno
de los más recientes planteamientos es
el de la economía circular que es un
sistema en el que se Procura aprovechar
todos los elementos y generar el mínimo
de desechos este tipo de aproximaciones
Creo que van a ayudar mucho en el futuro
por el lado de los paradigmas Aunque
surgió ya desde hace varias décadas
sigue siendo muy válido el apotema de
las tres erres rehúsa reduce y recicla
en resumen consumir menos por último
también en Twitter nos comentaron por
ejemplo desde México el caso de una
comunidad que se había quedado sin
suministro habitual de agua durante
semanas y que ahora viven con esa
preocupación Esa ansiedad de que vuelva
a suceder Cómo podemos enfrentar esta
incertidumbre
en México tenemos varias regiones que
año con año
reciente la falta o escasez de agua el
caso al que se refieren cobró mayor
notoriedad porque es una de las tres
principales ciudades contra población y
población Industrial en nuestro país en
este caso concreto se están ya planeando
obras de infraestructura mayor para
resolver el problema en un horizonte de
varios años para que ya no tengan
problemas durante 15 o 20 años pero en
tanto que siempre infraestructura está
lista lo mejor opciones siempre el
enfoque preventivo que el agua
disponible lo que se tiene ahora se usa
de mejor manera y que cada persona
internalice de su propio consumo su
propio manejo del agua es importante en
el conjunto para ello claro la
información y la sensibilización que
provengan tanto de la familia como de
parte de las autoridades es esencial en
resumen es un aspecto tanto educativo
como de conciencia y de actuación
individual hay que cuidar el agua que
tenemos
individuales pero también al doctor
colectivo al final Como siempre un
problema colectivo debe ser resultado
también resuelto de forma colectiva
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos en este
espacio y nosotros ponemos punto y final
aquí a este programa especial sobre
salud y cambio climático que ha contado
con la ayuda de Juliette riaño Natalia
Quiroga Laura garzón sigan con nosotros
en France 24
[Música]